the University of Edinburgh has found
itself in the firing line after rolling
out its red carpet for a so-called anti
racism conference that has banned white
people from asking questions during a
Q&A we will therefore not be given the
microphone to white people during the
Q&A not because we don't think why
people have anything to offer to the
discussion but because we want to
amplify the voices of people of color if
you're a white person with a question
please share it with a member of the
committee all our speakers after the
panel discussion the event was organized
by a group called the resisting
whiteness collective the organizers say
their aim is to raise awareness about
the importance of anti-racist actions in
the UK the host of the event however
have created two separate rooms called
safe spaces for those who could feel
overwhelmed or uncomfortable as one of
them barring white people from even
entering and bring university expressed
concern over certain aspects before the
event including the safe rooms the
university's officials claiming the
organisers have started reviewing that
particular point but no changes if any
were maids were ever published on the
official event page all of this has
provoked a strong reaction online this
sort of stupidity by Edinburgh
University actually fuels racism if the
idiots who came up with this idea lived
in the real world they'd know
inclusivity not apartheid is what's
needed Edinburgh University hosts racist
event banning Polish people from talking
the aim of the event is to end racism
presumably by actively being racist
they have come full circle in an effort
to become a non racist they've become
racist talk about overcompensating
I'm joined on the line now by David
Curtin who is a Briggs at Alliance
London Assemblyman there very good
evening - David what's your take on this
story I mean some people are claiming
this is reverse racism what do you think
of that claim
well it's blatant racism there's no such
thing as reverse racism racism is
excluding people because of the color of
their skin and this does that
yeah whereas before we've had the kind
of racism that excludes people and
discriminates against people because
they're black this blatantly
they're white and this doesn't do any
good for anybody whether they're white
or black or brown and this kind of thing
just simply should not be happening
there you get a few examples of
incidents like this and it feels like
people are always slightly afraid to do
anything about it for fear of being
called racist themselves so the
university I've got this situation
they've got a group I think they were
called resisting whiteness now if that
was called resisting blackness the
action they take would be pretty clear
this way around though they struggled
should they have given a platform to
this group and given the conditions in
which the group was operating well I'm
forgiving a platform for for any group
you know whatever anyone wants to say
but that's the whole problem with this
event is that they're not allowing a
platform for people who are white on the
basis of their color of their skin and
as you say if someone decided to put on
an event called resisting blackness can
you imagine the outrage which we would
have had from the same kind of people
who are putting on this event there
everyone would be up in arms from you
know people on the extremes of the
political spectrum and all of the
liberal if you like elite in the media
would be be writing about it condemning
it and we wouldn't hear the end of it
for days if not weeks and so that just
goes to show the kind of hypocrisy that
you've got in
academic circles these days they will
allow this event called resisting
whiteness to go ahead which is blatantly
racist against white people but they
wouldn't say a thing that they are
absolutely scared to death of being seen
to be politically incorrect we have this
politically correct culture which is
suffocating and people are just fed up
and sick and tired of it but it just
seems to go on and on and on and you
know the good thing about this is that
people have started to speak up not
people so much at the University who
were still scared who said nothing about
it but people in the country as a whole
have really just had enough of this kind
of thing okay many thanks David David
curtains my guests brexit alliance
London Assemblymember thank you
you